une star de la natation à poissy alain
bernard est venu ce mercredi 20 novembre
à la piscine mignot dans le cadre du
master class le double médaillé
olympique aux jo s'est glissé dans la
peau d'un entraîneur le temps d'un après
midi
ça me plaît parce que voilà j'ai des
anecdotes aussi dans mon passé qui m'ont
permis de rencontrer des champions je je
m'en souviens ça m'a marqué je m'en suis
servi et voilà ça peut avoir un impact
sur eux que ce soit quelque chose
d'assez quantifiable dans le sport ou
dans leur vie voilà si on contribuer à
leur épanouissement on aura rempli notre
mission
cette treizième dates de la tournée
française d'alain bernard était destiné
aux enfants du secteur âgés de 9 à 17
ans les jeunes sportifs ont pu se prêter
au jeu des questions réponses et nager
sous le regard de cet ancien
professionnel qui a stoppé sa carrière
en 2012 c'est très important pour moi
parce que on a quand même une grosse
mine grandes stars
des réalisations mondial s'est c'est
incroyable je trouve ces il est dit on
pourrait dire ça comme ça on voit en
champion olympique
c'est un grand honneur pour nous on n'a
jamais vu un champion olympique comme ça
on va voir les gros régionaux une fois
remis de leurs émotions les jeunes et
alain bernard ont terminé la session par
une séance photo l'occasion
d'immortaliser encore un peu plus cette
rencontre inédite